the grim reaper has officially come to
Riverdale again and so has that thing
let's try to figure this all out
together on Sweetwater secrets hi river
babes I'm Liana Galera and this is your
Riverdale after show for episode 302
chapter 37 Fortune and men's eyes which
was an epically bizarre episode that I
loved kind of not only will I be
breaking down my biggest hisses and
kisses so start sending me yours
I'm also gifting you with exclusive
answers from Luke Perry Machin emic and
Lily Reinhardt talking about the most
shocking and swoon worthy moments of the
night
but first let's quickly recap all the
jailhouse and bunker craziness in the
blue and gold breakdown you guys the big
man on campus is now in the big house
and Archie's first few days in jail were
not ideal when he wasn't getting shunned
from the serpent's or beat up by the
Ghoulies or getting his shoes stolen he
was trying to become BFFs with his new
cellmate Mad Dog animal would it kill
you like luckily his daily visits with
Veronica inspired him to rally the rival
games for a prison ride game of football
but because Hyrum doesn't have any other
hobbies he came to watch and with just
one little nod to the warden the guards
attacked the inmates and was pretty damn
brutal to watch meanwhile post-seizure
Betty decided to push past her floating
baby hallucinations and team up with
Jughead to uncover the mystery
surrounding Tilton's death my god
Tilton is dead oh yeah you guys Dalton's
officially gone and Ben's recovering in
the hospital and everything's gone to
hell so Nancy Drew and her boo
discovered that Ethel
or should I say princess ethylene was
also playing Griffin's and gargoyles and
she and her in the game boyfriend Ben
used to play together in Tilton's hidden
bunker in the woods he's following me
good because when Betty and Jughead went
into Fox Force to meet Ethel they ran
into this thing
apparently that glorified stick figure
is The Gargoyle King and Ethel is
completely terrified of it and then she
also had a seizure what is going on
luckily Ethel is okay but just when we
thought all was calm in Riverdale Betty
and jug went into Ben's room to check on
him and he was battling about joining
Tilton and then he did this fly to you
that to top it all off all the parents
of Riverdale got together in the same
room and they all looked amazing but
they basically alluded to the fact that
the Riverdale lien history is now
repeating itself they're in danger that
was a lot and as confused as I am and
loving this season so far so now it's
time to get some answers now we've been
told that there are no supernatural
elements in Riverdale but that gargoyle
king has me thinking otherwise so here's
what Lily Reinhart and me should Amick
have to say well with the gargoyle king
it almost seems supernatural as well so
I was trying to talk to her Bert oh
about this and he's saying that he's
keeping the two Mythology separate at
this point between Sabrina and Riverdale
yeah but yeah you know I understand that
you would see the gargoyle can you big
that's a monster that must be
supernatural but it really isn't yeah
but you Greendale is magical Riverdale
it's not they are towns that are side by
side I'm just saying maybe there's a
strange portal yeah now let's move on to
all the Riverdale romance in seven
seconds in heaven first up let me just
get this out of the way and say that
Tony topes wasn't even in this episode
so by default there was no Shoni while
I'm glad that we got to see more from
Cheryl and Veronica's friendship which
was very fun in season one I'm bummed
maybe you should channel that rage into
something more productive phallus at
least shared a scene together so there's
that and we did get a teeny tiny taste
of Mebane but there seems to be some
kind of dark cloud hanging over this
ship moose hasn't come out to his dad
yet and I get that everyone needs to
live their own life in their own time
but when you ignore Kevin Keller and he
says this moose are you ashamed of me
that's when I get mad his face is too
pretty to be sad now Veronica wins the
award for sweetest girlfriend thanks to
multiple visits to our chickens in jail
and
even though I thought the whole let's
before I'm just outside of the prison
gates moment was a little weird this
moment melted my heart who the hell is
that
it's my girl his girl kill me too cute
and as for bug head what's that saying
the couple who solves crimes together
makes out more have more romantic words
ever been spoken no yeah well here's
what Lily Reinhart had to say about
Betty and jugheads dynamic in this
episode and moving forward let's talk
about the fact that nothing brings Betty
and Jughead closer than a mystery to
solve
Roberto described it as the ultimate bug
head aphrodisiac oh yeah I guess I would
say that what can you tease what is
coming up for bug head this year because
season two is about a lot of up and down
back and forth yeah well so they
definitely tackled one of the bigger
mysteries of Griffins and gargoyles and
battling the gargoyle king together in
season 3 the first couple episodes are
them kind of digging deep straight into
that going headfirst side-by-side which
is really sweet to see and they really
are a team something unfortunate happens
which maybe causes a little disagreement
between them and some frustration but I
think they're you know every
relationship has some some bumps but I
think they come out on the other side
pretty well sound like things with bug
head will be a-okay but now it's time to
have some fun and unleash my kisses and
kisses first up in hisses that first one
is going straight to the missing
adventure scout who straight-up scared
the bejesus out of me and Betty
hisses - the Ghoulies for stealing our
cheese shoes that was weird and his
sister Hyrum for having a bunch of
innocent boys beat within an inch of
their lives
you're the worst go away you of course
had nothing better to do and hisses -
whatever happened to Archie's missing
roommate Mad Dog hisses - the
introduction of Evelyn ever never why
are you taunting Betty why are you
always just lurking in the corners what
secrets are you hiding girl not to worry
guys I'll have more details on this
mysterious new character in our next
preview episode of Sweetwater on
Wednesday so stay tuned yeah no worries
I totally understand this is - mousse
and tell me if you guys disagree but I
don't think he deserves Keven Keller
don't get me wrong I'm all for people
coming up to their parents when the time
is right and no one should feel rushed
but if Kevin Keller wants to date you
you let him date you
end of story hisses - Alison Polly for
trying to convince Betty that her
seizure was from stress and that those
floating babies were actually a quote
hallucination side note where are the
babies has anyone checked the bonfire
what about Juniper and equity are they
all right
and hisses - the parents keeping
Griffin's and gargoyles secrets here's
what--look Perry had to tell me when I
asked him about this in episode 302 we
discover that the parents all get
together and they know the secrets that
are behind the game of Griffins and
gargoyles what can you tease about what
secrets are hiding there's nothing new
Under the Sun right anything you've seen
has been done before yeah but these and
the parents are no different they had
their own brush with Griffins and
gargoyles when they were that age and
you know not jingle jangle but whatever
was jingling around at the time and we
come to find out some pretty dark stuff
we're gonna keep it going with hisses I
had more than I thought okay
hisses - the fact that Tony was totally
niña from this episode I'm pretty sure
she was supposed to be standing by her
boo during that vixens performance
mm-hmm now look I get it not every actor
is going to be in every episode but at
least throw us a teeny tiny line of
explanations please now on the flip side
kisses - our first vixens performance
and song of the season since we also
have absolutely no idea what's gonna
happen
Val and Mallory should we just make it
official and have Josie's permanent
Pussycats to be Ronnie and Cheryl they
do most of the singing anyways kisses to
Ronnie for always standing by her man
and while I'm digging your disguise girl
you look best as a raven-haired beauty
kisses to Betty and Jughead for finding
happy moments during dark times and for
doing more for the town of Riverdale
than sheriff Minetta ever will what
would you say you do here kisses - the
fact that we learned hotdogs dudes last
name before he died it's button and
kisses to Cheryl for this epic clap back
you can't discriminate against someone
because they're better looking than you
and lastly kisses to the gargoyle King
you're probably evil and I have no idea
what's going on but I love you way more
than the black hood and for that I'm
eternally grateful luckily for us
doesn't run very fast and we're done
thank you all so much for tuning in to
this Sweetwater Secrets after-show and
I'll see you next week for our preview
for episode 303 chapter 38 as above so
below and now I really want to hear from
you hit that subscribe button and then
shout out your hisses and kisses in the
comments below what do you think about
the gargoyle King do you think benna's
really of dead what do you think about
Ethel and Evelyn Sherilyn veronica join
josie as the Pussycats what is going on
the season tell me your thoughts I'll
talk to you soon River Braves bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]